so I'm talking about robust algorithms
in machine learning and elsewhere it's
more about robust algorithms and the
machine learning which is all about
throwing away information my name is Tom
Radcliffe I as many of the speakers here
today are am a physicist by education
I'm also a professional engineer which
is a Canadian thing I'm currently the
vice president of engineering at active
state which I'll talk about in a little
bit my physics career my engineering
career have wandered around a lot
including some very pure physics in in
terrestrial neutrino physics as well as
something called the Sudbury neutrino
Observatory for which the ahead of the
snow collaboration was awarded the Nobel
Prize for his work in proving that
neutrinos have mass the neutrinos are a
subatomic particle that are very
important to the evolution of the
universe not very important to most
practical things I've also done a lot of
work in Applied Physics in Medical
Physics image processing computer
assisted surgery particularly for
orthopedics and have done a lot of work
in data analysis for the biological
sciences particularly genomics mostly
looking at cancer genetics so in my last
academic position was a Nanjing
professor in pathology which is a weird
place for physicists to wind up working
on numerical analysis for a large
quantitative biological datasets people
who went into biology and medicine at
least you were my age didn't do so
because they loved math and in the 90s
we started to produce these large
numerical data sets in biology and
medicine and a lot of physicists wound
up there because it's fun and it makes
the world a better place and there are
some really hard problems I had my own
company predictive a Turing software and
as I said currently I'm the vice
president of engineering at active state
in Vancouver Canada which produces
something called active Python that
we've recently been in
I sing for data scientists for data
science and I'll talk about that in a
little bit we're the open sourcing
languages company active State started
back in 1997 to produce Perl on Windows
when Perl on Windows was a really hard
problem it subsequently added tickle and
Python distributions did a whole bunch
of other stuff the company has been
partially acquired several times for
technologies that has been developed but
the open source languages have always
been the core of the business and
providing enterprise support for open
source languages in particular we have
banks and insurance companies people
like this for clients who need stable
curated secure up-to-date distributions
of these various languages in 2017 we've
introduced active go it shipped a month
or two ago and we are going to launch
active ruby into beta this month and
there is more to come after that we also
make a nice polyglot IDE that's
optimized for dynamic languages called
Komodo it's a lot of fun it's there's a
there's a free trial download I
recommend it unless you're one of the
95% of developers who is already wedded
to a particular IDE
it's a difficult market to play in so
active Python used to be a pretty
vanilla distribution of Python it was
basically what you got with core Python
except up-to-date curated built for
cross-platform we have subsequently
added about 300 additional packages plus
their dependencies which comes in to
about 500 packages including a bunch of
things that are selected specifically to
aid with data science and machine
learning in one way or another Karis
piano tensorflow
pandas we heard in the keynote yesterday
that there's always a complaint about
the pandas interface I personally love
pandas I did a lot of work in our our is
a programming language you know
developed by infor statisticians pandas
has tried to capture all of that good
stuff that we get an hour in a pythonic
way and I think it's a really beautiful
tool
we don't have a third party package
manager' we've heard a lot about Conda
at this meeting and I think what it does
it does very well active state is very
much about focusing on what the
community is doing pip is not where it
once was in terms of its capabilities
it's gaining capabilities all the time
and if one wants to use pip or Conda for
that matter with active Python that's a
that's a perfectly possible thing and
we're very cross-platform our Community
Edition which is downloadable for free
for non production use in supports Mac
Windows and Linux but because we're an
enterprise company we also support for
our enterprise customers AIX and HP and
Solaris and and things of hopefully no
one in this room is is deeply engaged
with because they can be pretty
interesting platforms to work on for
modern data science applications the ml
libraries we support obvious is one of
the big ones I presume most people know
about it it is a common front-end to a
whole bunch of really powerful backends
Fianna with tensorflow are the big ones
we've just heard it this meteor I just
heard at this meeting that Microsoft has
released experimental support for C NGK
with Kerris this is really nice because
it means you can just be agnostic about
what fundamental back-end you're using
and the Charis interface is really very
nice so it's accessible and great for
rapid development and I'll show a little
example later on siano is not really an
ml lib but it has all the things you
need to create machine learning
workflows particularly evaluation of
mathematical expressions are very
efficient and it's one of the one of the
Charis backends tensorflow I'm not going
to talk about very much because I
presume people know about that but
pandas I just really want people to be
excited about pandas it does have this
are like data frame which is the best
thing ever if people have done data
analysis and Python in in pre pandas
days where you had to keep track of all
the labels on all your data by hand
data frames do that for you it also has
really intelligent indexing where you
can take pieces out of data frames based
on numerical index based on labels and
even on boolean conditions so you can
there's like a I'll show an example
later where there's a one line thing
that just takes and creates a new data
frame for for a bunch of cases where a
particular boolean condition is true it
is it is one of the things that makes
data analysis in Python and data science
in Python a real joy so that's kind of
some of the background on the tools I'm
using at least but I really want to talk
about robust algorithms mostly you know
I worked with with physical data of one
kind or another and all data has noise
we saw a nice example in the keynote
earlier this afternoon where there was a
data set that was supposed to be about
juvenile criminals or people who wound
up in some kind of social services
system in Maryland and some of those
individuals had ages that were
ninety-five in some had ages that were
zero where people were entering data
that was far outside of the actual
applicable range when you start
computing statistics around that having
these wild outliers in the data can
produce very significant distortions
which is why we do so much spend so much
time cleaning things up but no matter
how good we get at cleaning things up
there's always stuff left over and
robust algorithms are intended to deal
with the inherent noise problems so I'm
going to talk a little bit about
examples of actual problem some
algorithms that are popular one of the
things that make robust algorithms a
little bit opaque is there are lots of
them and they all have funny names that
are not very informative and it's not
always clear why you should be using
them or what you should be using them
for and then I'm going to talk about the
general approach of robustness and give
a real-world example of how one can use
the idea of robustness
even necessarily focusing on a specific
named algorithm the big thing about
parametric algorithms which are the
things the statistically speaking a
parametric algorithm is generally one
that assumes a distribution that
distribution is almost always a Gaussian
and it uses all the information
available it uses the quantitative
information in the in the data the
cardinal values of the data but those
Cardinals include noise as well as
signal and sometimes they include other
populations of data that can be badly
distorted of the the ultimate result
that we're looking for so as a physicist
I think about data in terms in a couple
of different ways one is we have a
physical process producing some signal
and we have a transducer that's
producing ultimately a measurement a
digital value of some kind that includes
both information about the world in the
signal plus noise of some kind and that
noise is not always well behaved it can
be signal dependent it can be time
dependent it can be episodic it can be
weird basically time dependent noise is
a fun thing if you do any work with
transducers in a building environment
like this one for example you will see
that everything becomes noisy at about
8:00 in the morning because people are
arriving at work and they're going up
and down in elevators which draw a great
deal of power which produce spikes on
the power all over the building so there
are effects like that that bleed through
into your data that you can't get away
from we also have a different type of
noise I'm a nuclear physicist we spend a
lot of time measuring when you're doing
radiation spectroscopy you're measuring
events basically where a detector says
you know a gamma ray came in and had
this much energy and you have events
from the sources you care about and you
have events from the sources you don't
care about which may be real they may be
cosmic rays may be other forms of gamma
radiation or they may be electrical
noise in the system so you get a
background signal that is completely
different from the physical process that
you really care about that it can have
any distribution whatsoever and and
frequently does so I'm going to give an
example of a particular case that I've
worked on without it without worrying
about where the where the data comes
from of an automated test instrument for
bacteria in water where there was a case
in Canada where an incompetent municipal
operator killed a lot of people because
there was a back there was a high level
of bacteria in the water
they didn't get caught in testing so
there was significant government
investment in producing better water
testing that was automated and idiot
proof so this instrument was designed to
be just completely fire-and-forget you
pour the water and you stick the
cartridge into the instrument everything
would work that's a very highly
constrained system from the point of
view of engineering design the input
data quality cannot be made arbitrarily
good you have to sell it for an
affordable price which limits
what goes into it and there's underlying
physics chemistry and biology that
messes up the signal in various ways so
there was a certain level of badness in
the data that we just had to live with
and this is very typical when we talk
about the internet of things most of the
data that comes in from various sensors
is going to be affected by issues of
this kind the ideal data is this nice
kind of sigmoid curve where it's a
growth curve for some bacteria and we're
looking for when does it cross looks
pretty easy when you look at it like
this there's a little constraint where
it has to be as fast as possible we
don't want to wait 24 hours if the
threshold was crossed at you know 5
hours which is a heavily contaminated
sample and we want it to work under all
circumstances we want to be very very
robust and if we get it wrong there is a
potential you know
to human health if we say yeah there's
no problem and there is one and because
of the nature of the growth process
we're looking at there is an exponential
sensitivity to errors in where the
threshold is crossed the real data looks
a little more like this it has some
signal dependent noise which is
extremely common so if you look at the
baseline down low you'll see that the
noise is fairly small but there's a much
fatter curve up top because the more
signal produces more noise and there's
also some threshold instruments rarely
have true zeros you're almost always
sitting on top of some threshold which
is going to vary from instrument to
instrument and then in fact because of
various issues with the engineering of
the system there are in the real
instruments these step functions in the
threshold level the change from time to
time based on essentially random
processes it's related to build up
pressure in one particular component due
to gas evolved by some bacteria so this
becomes dependent on all kinds of
extraneous issues that we have no
control over and that's just the simple
stuff when users we looked over
thousands and thousands of samples
pulled out a whole range of anomalies
trying to produce a robust detector that
wasn't going to be messed up by these
things so we saw different growth curves
we saw bacteria that got tired after a
while we saw bacteria with with you know
sudden onset all kinds of things and
accounted for as many of those as
possible but in deployment this is a
system that will run potentially
millions of tests per year so one in a
million chances are going to come up a
lot and this is something I think that
we forget about when we talk about big
data it's like wow we have all this data
this is great it means that really rare
occurrences are going to be happening
all the time in somebody's data stream
and that when we come to analyze that
we've got to be robust against those
unex
kids that we can't realistically
anticipate everything that can go wrong
simply because the scope of data is so
much larger than what we can reasonably
analyze so that's just an example and
I'm not going to talk about how that
particular problem was solved but we
managed it and I just wanted but it
makes a point the parametric algorithms
are sensitive to all those weird effects
they're designed to use all the
information that is coming in including
the pieces that don't contain
information about the problem we care
about so that you'd agree badly in the
presence of anomalies and when we talk
about moving from data science to data
engineering in particular we have got to
have systems that are robust against all
the strange things that are going to
happen in our data streams we seen in a
number of talks over the last two days
people talking about the amount of time
the data scientists spend cleaning up
data and I've done this myself the 50
percent or 80 percent of the time that
we spend cleaning data when it comes to
deployment into the real world
we don't have the opportunity to to dig
in and review the anomalies at that
level so automated cleaning super
important we always are going to have to
do stuff at that level but we have to
acknowledge that as data scientists we
genuinely deal with stuff that's more
pristine than our poor algorithms will
be facing when they go out into the real
world robusta fires of a notion of
robustness is fundamentally about
replacing our quantitative data with
something else and ranking is a big one
I'll talk about a bunch of algorithms
that use ranked data so all we care we
don't care about that this value is one
that value three that values five that
value is 15 we only care that they go in
that order and that can be 1 10 40 and
100 it's all the same they rank the same
way and that immediately makes us robust
against a bunch of outliers so when you
consider the the data I was talking
about earlier where there were a bunch
of ninety five year-olds in this
juvenile data set that handful of data
instead of being out at 95 where the
mean is 15 those data would just be the
ones at the top of the distribution it
would be like there were a bunch more 18
year-olds in that data set it reduces
the kind of leverage effect of these
wild outliers counting things is another
robusta fire as soon as we just start
counting stuff the law of large numbers
kicks in and everything starts to look
pretty Gaussian it's a it's a really
wonderful phenomenon counting and and
then the third one is looking at signs
whether something's going up or going
down
that becomes accounting signs becomes
really robust zero is often a important
number where you know whether whether
whether the trend is in one direction or
the other and that direction can very
often be more important than the actual
rate of change and by throwing away the
rate of change we're also throwing away
all the noise in the rate of change so
the theory is we're going to throw away
information right sounds crazy
hopefully we will throw away more noise
than signal and this proves to be the
case in a remarkable number of
situations there have been cases where
I've applied robust algorithms and
things have not gotten better I don't
think I've ever encountered the case
where I've applied robust algorithms and
things have gotten worse it's it's a
remarkably powerful set of techniques it
also has two very nice consequences one
of which is really really important
which is it reduces the need to tune
parameters on our algorithms and it
often reduces a number of parameters and
because the underlying distribution of
the things like counting numbers are
well known distribution signs I've got
well known
Tribune's it gives us some objective
guidance as to how to tune those
parameters one of the things you'll find
with statistical analysis in particular
and machine learning in general is
there's a bunch of parameters and not
necessarily any great guidance on how to
tune them one of the examples given by
one of the keynotes
was we are like at the age where James
Watt has just invented the the modern
steam engine and machine learning is
like this it's the steam engine that's
going to drive industrial development in
the 21st century and I think there's
more to that analogy than maybe meets
the eye because James Watt
didn't know anything about
thermodynamics that understanding came a
hundred years later and there's still a
great deal of what we do with deep
learning in particular where we have the
tools we have the engine we know we know
basically how to make it run but we
don't have anything like what is
required to do a detailed theoretical
analysis and optimize the design in a
principled way for a particular case and
robustness kind of just puts that all on
the side or at least a great deal of it
by bringing us back into a space where
we understand the underlying
distributions a little better and as I
said earlier the other thing the real
payoff for robustness is the data
engineering context is that it degrades
gracefully as as bad things happen where
as parametric algorithms tend to do a
little better in the normal case and
then fall over badly when something
unexpected happens so I'm going to talk
a little bit about about actual named
nonparametric tests or robust tests
there are a bunch of them they all have
these almost all have these two barreled
names kruskal-wallis mann-whitney
kolmogorov-smirnov they they also they
go by they go by multiple names as well
the mann-whitney u test is also the
wilcoxon test
I sometimes envisioned statisticians in
the 1950s and 1960s just having as their
mission
in life to get their name attached to a
statistic because that's how you how you
live on so the names are uninformative
and and somewhat scary but they're the
tests themselves or at least
conceptually quite simple there's some
nuance in the in the in the application
so I'm going to talk about
kruskal-wallis which is like a
nonparametric F test it measures
difference in variants between
distributions mann-whitney u is like a
students t-test it measures a difference
in mean without worrying about whether
or not things are Gaussian I just
mentioned Kendall's tau and Spearman's
rank because they are common cases where
we're looking at two variables and
asking whether or not there's an
association between them so they're a
little bit like a nonparametric
r-squared and nobody should be using R
squared in the first place because it's
a terrible statistic so they're much
better even parametric measures of
Association so the T test versus the
mann-whitney you like I said they both
basically measure the difference in
means of distribution so if you're
looking at you know some some quantities
where you have two different populations
you want to know whether or not the
means are the same for the t-test the
statistic assumes that these things are
Gaussian and the variances are equal
which is very frequently violated
especially in a manufacturing context if
you're looking at things like quality
control tests on an assembly line
whereas the mann-whitney u test is quite
intuitive it asks for if you draw pairs
of data from these two populations
what's the probability of one being
higher than the other and if you really
have the same mean then you'll basically
have equal probabilities of one being
higher than the other and you generate
this u statistic based on that which
itself has a distribution that's
independent of the underlying
distribution of the data and that's
important because it means you can turn
you into a p-value without knowing what
the underlying distribution looks like
that's the key thing because what you'd
like is a p-value you'd like to know is
a significant or a p-value or something
like it the F test as I said is the F
test is the parametric test the F test
is looking and asking the same question
about the variances of distributions so
if I have
two distributions is one fatter than the
other is one more spread out than the
other the f-test to generate the p-value
ultimately have to assume that you have
a Gaussian with different variances and
the kruskal-wallis test looks at the
variances of the rank so if you take two
populations you can just rank you'll
rank them all together and then ask is
one of them more spread out than the
other in the in the overall ranking if
you take the two together it has a very
nice property they generate the
statistic that has a chi-square
distribution if the numbers are
sufficiently large generally the I
should have mentioned for the
kruskal-wallis test to to make it easy
you need about 20 samples which in this
day and age is not hard to get it used
to be much harder kruskal-wallis 5
samples not hard to get I have on
occasion had clients who were biologists
come to me and want to get data analysis
done until and I in your first thing you
ask it how big is your data set and
sometimes they'll say oh I have two
samples I have I have a control control
tissue and diseased tissue what can you
tell me you can actually sometimes tell
them things but maybe what they want to
hear I'm going to mention the nekoma
Gardener table test the Kolmogorov in
the kolmogorov-smirnov test if people
though any information theory is the
Kolmogorov of coma grown complexity and
and all that one of the the great
russian mathematicians of the mid 20th
century and it looks at the cumulative
distribution function on ranked data
which is good for looking at deviations
from an expected distribution I've used
this for spectral analysis in gamma
spectroscopy it has a very interesting
characteristic most robust tests are a
little less sensitive than their
parametric equivalents coma Girish mirov
is actually really sensitive and it also
is highly robust so it's one case it's
the kind of thing you would expect
Calma Ghorab to be associated with it's
just the best
it is it doesn't come up that often as a
need but it's a it's a really good and
powerful test where'd you find these at
a Python conference everything and more
is in Syfy stats man when do you
kruskal-wallis komagawa Smirnov and all
the parametric tests a t-test DF tests
they generally have very similar
interfaces or even the same so you can
just swap cats out and see the
difference which is a nice thing to be
able to do and you'll see from the from
the values here there are two problem
hard problems in programming cache and
validation and naming and if you look at
that list you can see that this is not a
problem in cache invalidation everything
is oddly named and it can be sometimes
hard to find but they are there and the
docs are pretty decent actually the docs
are really good now for for Syfy in
practice if you go out there and look
and ask you know look at the look on the
web and ask what when should I be using
a nonparametric test you'll get a lot of
stuff from data scientists and your
scientists generally that say basically
parametric tests work really well even
when the data aren't that well behaved
and this is absolutely true most of the
time it's hard to generate synthetic
cases where parametric tests really fail
it's relatively easy to find real cases
so when you start looking at your own
data when they fail badly because you
get this situation where imagine having
an alligator detector and you most
alligators look pretty much the same and
then one in like a million has this
they're called Lu technic or something
they're this really strange mix of
colors and those are the ones where your
parametric algorithms will fall over as
a data scientist it may not matter so
much when you're deploying these things
into the real world when you have
medical or health related questions that
are dependent on them you would like to
handle those questions a little
a little better that's the big thing so
this is the thing so when one moves from
data science to data engineering you
don't get the opportunity to look at the
data which is a fundamental thing that
is the basis of all Sciences is what
scientists do we look very closely at
the data at the distributions even the
individual cases and that gives us a big
premium on robust and fault tolerant
algorithms that's the that's the story
and I don't think that robust algorithms
are often taught or as an afterthought
in statistics classes at least in my day
or not at all and I just I'm basically
here to spread the gospel of robustness
because I think it's something that we
should think more about by default their
computationally often quite expensive
but we have computational power to burn
these days so I think there's less
excuse for not using them so as I said
anytime you can count you get the law of
large numbers the variance is equal to n
everything is Gaussian everything is
good the sign test just looking at
whether or not things are going up and
down is actually the oldest robust
statistics we have data on it was used
by a guy who is a contemporary of
mutants back in the late 1600s signs
have a binomial distribution and it
generally has low power but it's really
robust and in noisy datasets it can do
quite remarkable things I'm just going
to give a little example of that which
is stock picking which is a known hard
problem nobody knows what stocks are
going to go up and I looked in a data
set from the last seven years basically
one of the longest bull markets in
history 1800 and some days of data and
just ask if stocks are if there are
stocks that in the past went out more
frequently than expected is that
predictive of them going up more
frequently in the future I'm not asking
how much they went up by and I'm not
asking even whether or not they went up
over time just from a day to day basis
if they went tended to go up more often
than you would expect day to day did
they continue to do that over time
this is just a very very simple analysis
using pandas we're in it pandas is
really if anybody's not using pandas you
should be it is you can read if you use
a CBS file CSV file in and it does
things like you want to take the
difference in the time series you just
take the difference super easy this is
one of one of the great things where you
can build a data frame from a data frame
on a boolean condition where it's just
one line no loops no mucking about with
internal data structures pandas handles
all that for you and then you can do
some counting it's very intelligent it
does the things that you would expect it
to do it's one of those things where as
a data scientist it feels like it was
written you know really for people like
me and then you can do some simple
things it's got some rudimentary
plotting built-in where you can generate
a histogram and just show the histogram
and ask the question will there be
stocks that stand out but then I counter
the days over this data set the
particular stocks have gone up on a day
to day basis just with a one day
difference and the answer is not so much
I love this graph because it makes all
the marketing people really cringe when
I show up they say you can't show that
to people I'm talking to data scientists
they'll understand it's not pretty but
it conveys all the information we need
there's about 1800 worth days worth of
data in in the sample so we expect 900
ish to be the the average number of days
that things would go up if it was just
5050 but we know in bull markets that
stocks tend to go up sixty percent of
the time so we would expect more like
1,200 days and we don't get 1,200 days
on a day to day basis stocks don't tend
to go up sixty percent of the time but
when they do they go up more than they
go down and that accumulates over time
to produce the trend that we see
long-term trend we do however see that
some stocks go out more often than
others we do have a set out here that
have a tendency in that direction and we
can ask the original question so if we
split the data in two and we take the
first nine hundred and some days look at
the stocks that go up more frequently
the very tail of that distribution in
those first nine hundred days do more of
those stocks or those stocks
over-represented in the stocks that go
up in the second nine hundred days so
that's that's what gives us predictive
power in this case and if we look at
this if we do that we find that there
are 18 stocks at the top of the
distribution with some fairly arbitrary
threshold and if we do the same thing we
have 42 top stocks at the top of the
distribution in the second half of the
data and seven of those are in common
whereas from randomness alone we would
expect to have one in common if I just
chose 18 at random and 42 at random and
asked what the random overlap would be I
would expect to get one in common so
instead we get seven this is super
significant now I don't know I don't
think I'm going to run out here and and
get rich there's a huge difference
between something which is statistically
significant and operationally actionable
which is something whenever we do
statistics in a operational context of
something we really have to keep in mind
that it's easy to get hugely significant
effects this is like you know P equals
10 to the minus whatever but it may not
be useful to actually make money I don't
know I didn't look into it that deeply
because every time I do it never comes
to anything so however we have we have
demonstrated that stocks that are more
likely to go up on a daily basis in the
past are significantly more likely to go
up on a daily basis in the future and
yeah it doesn't even mean those stocks
go up within time with time those stocks
could actually be going down but tend to
go up a little bit more frequently and
then have big drops I didn't dig into
those questions lad that can be left as
an exercise for the interested student
the final bit of the of the talk I just
want to say okay well I have I have this
significant effect now now let's just
jump forward into machine learning and
say does this yo can can we do any of
any of these amazing deep learning
techniques and get predictions out of
this by looking at the fraction of
updates per month to the last 12 months
and try to predict the direction in the
next quarter okay so we're going to look
three months ahead so we're just we're
taking our signs as a ratio and throwing
it into under a level the thing I love
about tariffs is that's this easy to
build a deep neural network and this is
something there's not a lot of deep
thought put into this network
architecture because I was pretty sure
what the answer would be but is
unbelievably easy to just build a
network connect it up and then train it
with in this case of stochastic gradient
descent minimizer and looking at the
accuracy on the on the mean square error
and you just fit it with a bunch of
bunch of training data back in the day
when we were certainly certainly before
Python even building neural networks was
a huge pain and and caris is just I
think I'm using the piano back in here
but it could be tensorflow and now it
could be CNT k it's a really wonderful
front-end to - all these powerful tools
and the initial result was this thing
with 60% accurate and wow that sounds
good but the stock market goes up 60% of
the time so in fact the network
optimized correctly on a quarterly basis
by simply predicting it would always go
up alright and that is just a little
cautionary tale on I I give a off to
have given a variant of this talk
particularly to audiences that are very
rich in students learning machine
learning for the first time so this is a
bit of a cautionary tale for them to
make sure that training classes are
always represented
in your training data regardless of what
they are in the real world data make
sure that you randomly select the
training and test data
don't don't cheat in that regard and one
of the things I talked like talk about
is what I call meta / training where we
take a network architecture and and we
train and we test and then it doesn't
work very well so we tweak the network
architecture and we train and we test on
the same data and it doesn't work very
well so we do it again and we do it
again and we do it again and it's very
easy these days to train and test
hundreds of network architectures and
then one of them works well on the test
data and we say hurray we've solved the
problem but the significance of that
test has to be divided by the number of
network architecture to run things
through it's it's very easy to fool
ourselves and if you're a scientist I
mean sometimes that's a publishable
result right it's it's very easy then we
see this in other areas as well where we
applied just a mass of statistical tests
of things we get one the significant
nets one we published it's very easy to
fool ourselves when we are when we're
when we're one badly to get a particular
result so always test and always be
honest with the with the day with the
training data the test data so in
conclusion increased robustness may
reduce power in cases like comedor
enough you don't actually get any power
reduction and it is when there is a
power reductions usually not too bad we
can very frequently even when not using
a named test get our data into a robust
form doing things like counting signs
doing things like just counting stuff
and if we understand the basic
distribution of large numbers or
binomial distributions we can use those
very directly in our analysis and
finally robustness is not a silver
bullet even though I had a statistically
significant thing there it didn't
necessarily result in any predictive
payoff so that is it thank you
and we have time for questions
yeah because of the needs of the
prediction problem or because you see
that are not nice in the data you see
you would say that against Leyton
so when you introduce or would not into
the data is that because of the needs of
the traditional problem or because that
because of the noise in it is
fundamentally the noise in the data yeah
yeah it's almost always that yeah yes it
was I what the reason to what is the
motivation to introduce the openness is
that because of the needs of the
analysis of it is whether yeah whether
the motivation is is whether whether
motivated by the needs of the analysis
or noise and the data it generally is
noise in the data that that drives this
it's you can always you can always
replace a robust analysis with a
parametric analysis or vice versa there
are always multiple ways of answering
the same question
it's always the noise it drives the
choice of the Russ's yep so the things
you cover verbose please justify
Pappas's yep some sort so you want to
add why this kind of methodology to
machine learning out them through your
training them would that just be
something as simple as difficulties of
beating
repeating the recs in the future yeah
this is a question was this is all
statistical hypothesis testing what
would one do if you were just wanted to
do like straight-up machine learning and
would you just feed in robust measures
like the ranks of the feature rather
than the value of the feature and the
answer is yes you would choose you can
feed things like ranks directly into
machine learning algorithms with the
caveat that they tend to be discrete I
mean they are discrete in that case and
that can produce issues for some machine
learning algorithms yeah potentially
yeah or you can do things like I did
with the did here I took the ratio of
sines for example which is a little more
continuous distribution rather than just
account which becomes very discrete Tim
first thing you sorry yes what would you
mean by I'm not sure I understand the
question
yep oh yeah yeah so the question is are
there any sampling techniques that could
be applied to this the answer is yes
absolutely these things are all you know
100% resampling friendly so you can you
can basically do resampling on the ranks
the same way you would do on Cardinal
data yeah yes so a lot of you know the
Chan now is to use a different network
we learn the feature instead of just you
know the Java the enemies to contact the
feature yeah and when you use that most
of the algorithm is used some sort of
you know a guardian you know yeah
algorithm we could go into local Optima
way too much sweat that that local akima
is not very it's really yeah there's two
aspects to that question one is I'm old
so I don't necessarily totally buy into
the notion of using the deep learning
mechanisms to extract the features I
think there's still a very significant
role for human intelligence in this but
I've worked mostly with smaller datasets
so as I do the example I gave in biology
where you've got two samples one disease
one control you can handle those cases
by enhancing the human intelligence what
I did in that case was told the
researcher go away and give me do a
literature review give me a bunch of
genes that you think half of those genes
you think will differ between the two
samples then I'll do a numerical
analysis see which genes actually differ
in their expression and we'll look at
the overlap of the lists and if your
jeans are over represented in my list
then we know something but that's not a
deep learning problem the fundamental
thing about keeping out of a local
optima is add noise and do it again
right start things from different random
starting points and see whether or not
they converge that's the the biggest
deal and it multiplies the amount of
work that you have to do I worked on a
very complex multimodal 2d 3d image
registration problem for computer
assisted surgery that was a minimizer in
a very noisy environment ultimately and
the only way to make it robust was to
give it multiple random starting points
and and make sure that they all converge
to the same place yeah and tweak the
network architectures to tweak
everything yes so using or introducing
openness come with a prize why you say
that you may use information yes so how
do you make a decision okay when you're
going to introduce openness instead of
using
using right yep you said you know
valuable so the question is because
we're buses can have consequences in
terms of losing power how do you make
the decision whether or not things need
to be robust taste and experience which
is not a great answer I don't have any
strong when you look at the data
basically you look at a lot of data and
you ask are there anomalies are there
outliers and ideally you you try both
and and see which one gives you better
results and and on alert on the largest
data set you can find so there's a bit
of trial and error sort of one question
over here the LT yep generally yes
probably but there are other cases where
anytime where you have a value that
might be positive or negative yeah well
you what you really need because you're
always talking about data that's
attached to an entity right so whenever
you have an Antony that has multiple
values associated with it in gene
expression data
we're often looking for genes that are
upregulated versus downregulated
right and that's typically done
quantitatively with some kind of full
difference but you could as well when
comparing say a cancer tissue sample
versus normal tissue sample simply ask
count the genes that are upregulated
where your relative some baseline versus
the genes that are down regulated so it
wouldn't be a time series but anytime
you have multiple measures associated
with a single entity you can start to
ask about counting signs yes yeah sorry
there was somebody over here yes how
would you say how how our bust our
Bayesian Bayesian analysis when it comes
to outliers and data when compared to
this oh so the question is how robust
are Bayesian analyses when when looking
at these the answer is super robust in
general I am a card-carrying Bayesian we
should all be doing using Bayesian
methods
this is very conventional statistical
talk because that's the language that
statisticians use to talk about
robustness but basically all of this can
be cast in Bayesian language because you
ultimately God created the probability
distribution functions all else is a
work of man so we hit this one we're
trying to do here is is get the problem
into a form where we have a well-known
probability distribution function that
allows us to run Bayesian methods on it
okay yep Kenneth's example you showed
you use the box and mean square there
yes you know in a chaotic guess code yes
thank you is creator in fourth month yes
I think I wonder why you didn't use
cosine Sophia
Oh jury means good because I'm old the
question is why did I use mean square
instead of a cosine yeah so yeah
basically because I'm old that's it
because in my day we use mean square but
but you're probably correct yeah yeah oh
but it's also compares to a realization
I'm saying out the bus's approach
compares to regularization yeah I got
yeah regularization generally requires
some kind of supervening knowledge where
you have some idea of what things should
look like so in the cases where you have
that and can apply that in a principled
way it can be a very powerful technique
in the problems I've worked on mostly we
haven't had that so the danger of
regularization is that you're imposing a
view on the data and if you're wrong you
that can result in in incorrect results
so yeah that's the it then so
fundamentally the choice there depends
on how much information you have and how
much you trust it am first I was just
wondering if you can talk more about
handling imbalance classes one of them
I'm under the impression that if you
resemble you might be optimizing for say
area under curve at the expenses of
collaboration yep our surgeon for models
prone to that broadly broadly speaking
you should I mean ideally your your
training data your real data like your
full data set should have pretty equal
representation of all your classes and
if you can't do that if you're really I
mean but some problems don't present us
with that you know 60/40 is not bad but
I have worked in again in biological
samples where you get three or four
different cancer types and and you know
ninety percent of them or more are the
three and you've got this tiny little
sample of the of the other one in that
case ultimately you need more data right
that's the correct solution beyond that
you you have to you underweight somehow
the the sample you have the least of
because you've got a deist occurred in
using chronic features in there you've
got and you don't want that limiting
your analysis in some cases you simply
want to exclude the smallest class or
break the analysis up to get a
multi-class problem so that you do that
class versus everything else and then
analyze the within class problem in the
larger data set separately then would
chat sigit sagen [ __ ] boost yeah
yeah bootstrapping yeah yeah I'm not a
big bootstrapping fan but yeah so you
wanted to represent in your answer that
basically regularization kind of maps to
their invasion analysis to finding your
prior yeah if you've got a good prior
that's the basic that'sa basically if
you've got a good prior and I love to
have a good prior but I often don't
right and yeah so anything else or are
we done Oh
more sorry him first then you
Rankin's USD do production come is that
rapping actually based on human domain
dollars no it's literally numerical
ranking so if I've got cardinal values
that are like one point two three point
four four point five
they're just ranked they did one two
three yeah it's just replacing the
Cardinals with the ordinals yep what
general thoughts on a difference which
called meta overtraining and hyper
parameter optimization so like boy I
prefer inverter over over you I mean we
can't get away with it okay guy we can't
get away from it rather because we've
got a finite amount of data
what type of parameter optimization
ultimately reduces the statistical
significance of our final result right
and then we have to we if you if do what
I like to do really is is the way we do
if you've got enough data which most of
these days we do take a big block of
data and make that your training set
hyper parameter optimized like mad on
that but then once you've done that use
that other chunk is a true training set
for your optimized or test set rather
for your optimized network that's the
thing you do because otherwise the
internal and I've seen papers published
that are basically worthless because
what they've done is tuned up the
network until they happen to get a good
result on the train on the test set but
it's not robust it doesn't carry over to
ultimate to to general data so you're
saying how about a training validation
and has set yes yes so yeah yeah it is
four o'clock and I think it's time to go
home
thank you very much
[Applause]